this Black Friday you can get arisin 7
1700 x an eight-core 16th red cpu for
only 150 dollars just from that if you
didn't realize how good of a deal this
is
here's some more pricing information to
put it all into perspective the risin 7
1700 X came out for $400 so this is
pretty much a sixty two point five
percent discount this Rison 7c view is
literally cheaper than the Rison five
and Intel i5 out there as a result there
really is no reason to go with the risin
5 or Intel i5 CPU if you're considering
either those cheap use then this is
definitely PU for you even if you're
considering a rising 3 or Intel i3 CPU I
strongly recommend you shall have some
extra money and go for this CPU but this
deal will not be available again clearly
New York is trying to get rid of their
original Rison 7 Series CPUs right now
so they can get some more room for the
rising third generation so as a result
this CPU will not be offered for a
better price in the future so even if
you're considering a rising 3 or Intel
i3 CPU to just spend the extra 52 cents
per dollars and go for this beast you
definitely will not regret it
what if you want something better like
the rise in 720 700 X which is - top of
the line of mainstream right and CPU
offered from AMD currently even then
horizon 7 1700 X is very very close with
the 2700 X the only differences between
the risin 7 7200 X and horizon 7 2700 X
is that the 2700 X base and boost clocks
or 0.4 gigahertz faster on the rise and
717 her ex the base clock is 3.40 Hertz
and a boost clock is 3.8 on horizon 727
airbags the base clock is 3.8 gigahertz
and a bruise clock is 4.3 so basically a
point for 2.5 a her difference however
there's still one crazy difference
between them the rise in 727 X right now
cost three hundred and twenty dollars on
you egg so this is literally less than
half of that on Black Friday it is
likely the 27 X will drop in price into
the high to hundreds but even then the
7:17 Rex because way ahead of it but
there is one thing to keep in mind the
27 Rex will come with a nice top cooler
all 17 Rex will not so if you're
considering an i3 i5 or i7 or if you're
considering rising 3 risin 5 arisin 7
for this Black Friday then this TP right
here is definitely the way to go because
its value is absolutely unbeatable also
there's no reason to be concerned with
rising 3rd generation it may actually be
an octa-core 5 you heard beast like all
the rumors suggest Harvard it will also
be in the 300s so the value that is
being offered right here with the 700 X
will not be beaten finally don't wait
till the last day to make a decision
make a decision today if you want to CPU
or not this is a very steep discount and
as a result many people will have their
eyes on it you know abaya as soon as
they possibly can so it will go out of
stock very quickly so right now make a
strong decision whether you're gonna buy
it or not you may want to get the 8700 K
or 97 order K or a rise in Fredericks
CPU and there's nothing wrong with that
just to make the decision today so that
you are not in a situation where you're
like you want to buy it but it's out of
stock and you're too late overall this
is the best value CPU out there for
Black Friday secret considering a new
mainstream CPU for this Black Friday and
give to CPU a very strong consideration
but that's pretty much all I wanted to
tell you guys in this video right here
so what do you guys think about this CPU
are you going to be taking advantage of
this deal or are you not going to be
taking advantage of this deal make sure
to comment down below what you guys
think base I'm actually very curious as
to how you guys make your purchasing
decisions also if you guys like this
video make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing if you like to see
more videos just like this one but until
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]